oh
why hello there i'm dave rubin this is
the reuben report direct message for
today
march 8 and we've got a show
chock full of information for you people
i'm going to actually go through
the 1.9 trillion dollar
covid relief bill that our benevolent
leaders have passed they're going to
give
us stuff and i'm sure that everything in
the bill
is worthwhile and it's not for their own
interests
it's for us the peons the good people
who need them
to lead us we're going to talk about
that we're going to talk about bernie
sanders who is
just awful i mean just
an awful awful human being i try not to
besmirch people personally but this guy
at this point
old socialist not good not good and then
we're gonna do a couple other
stories we're mixing it up today uh
before i do anything else though guys
quick reminder to subscribe
to our youtube channel and click that
notification
bell and i was gonna talk
about coming to america because i saw
the the sequel coming
to america on uh was it on amazon
prime this weekend but my guys have told
me it's best because in case people
didn't see it i don't want to do any
spoilers yet
so i'm not going to talk about that but
i will tell you that i was walking the
dog yesterday
and you know still a lot of really
depressed lunatics here in los angeles
and people walking around with masks
outdoors and i keep telling you they
they pull dogs out of the way so dogs
can't say hi
and sniff butts and it's just it's just
very depressing all these people you see
people
driving alone with masks on and just the
whole thing
but anyway yesterday we were walking the
dog and a woman ran up to us
and she said oh my god dave rubin i love
you so much i live right here and we're
so happy
that you're here i don't really love the
fact that people kind of know where i
live but she's oh so happy so happy
and she said dave don't worry there are
others like us in the area
that's nice to hear it's nice to know
that there are others now it depends i
guess what her definition of
like us is non-reptilian people
i suppose but sane people it means that
i'm surrounded by somewhat
sane people every now and again there's
others like us that's sort of what's
happening in society right now
as we watch like the layer of everyone
just go completely bananas that
people have to meet on the streets and
you can sort of tip off she didn't have
a mask you can sort of tip off
oh you're not wearing this maybe you're
somewhat sane are you a little bit sane
and
maybe we can work with that sanity and
figure out what else is going on there
so you know a couple sane people
here in los angeles but all right let's
get to it joe biden
the apparent president of the united
states at least for a little while
longer
he passed a 1.9
trillion dollar covered stimulus bill
now first off i want to put up
this washington post headline i saw this
on twitter and if you want to see what
truly propaganda is what sort of
full on face
absolute propaganda is this headline
is it biden's stimulus showers
money on americans sharply cutting
poverty
in defining move of a presidency okay
now first off biden stimulus showers now
you understand that when they give you
stuff that means that they
took from you now i get that all these
numbers are made up and we're going to
go into some of the numbers a minute and
it's 1 trillion for this and 350 billion
for this
and it's all just made up numbers that
get us further into debt and we'll owe
china more and more and eventually we'll
have to go to war with china because
you know at some point it's just sort of
like the mafia you keep borrowing money
from somebody and if you can't pay them
back
you kind of have to you hope that your
muscles bigger than their muscles so
none of this ends well but
putting that aside for a moment the
framing of that biden
stimulus showers money on americans joe
biden he's jesus people and he gives he
gives you money that's what jesus did
right
but then the line that really got me
there the couple words that really got
me
sharply cutting poverty in defining move
of presidency now we're going to get to
the numbers in a second but basically
americans under uh 75 000 a year are
going to get
1400 okay
sharply cutting poverty if anyone
gets that 1400 check is there literally
one person in america
who will be moved out of poverty for
that 1400
check that is not to say some people
won't benefit from it of course they
will and that's
that's great right that's great if you
need the money the government it's the
least they can do give you back some of
the money that they sold for me in the
first place
okay so that's just fine sharply cutting
poverty no
that is a hundred percent lie it's not a
99.9 lie it's 100 lie
not one person got out of poverty or
will get out of poverty
because the government gave them
fourteen hundred dollars while at the
same time ramping up the national debt
which ultimately makes the money worth
less i mean i understand that democrats
basically believe you can just
print money and that there's nothing
behind it that's sort of the the whole
premise
behind everything they do but it's also
the defining move of his presidency
that's pretty incredible the guy's only
been president
for seven weeks he's only been awake for
maybe four to five hours of the whole
thing
so very interesting so from fox news the
bill includes fourteen hundred dollar
stimulus checks for individuals who make
less than seventy five
hundred dollars inmates are included
among those who receive stimulus checks
just as they were
in both previous cobit relief bills that
offered
1200 and 600 dollar checks so just one
more time on this 1400
thing and the idea that this got anyone
out
uh that's 75 000 by the way obviously
so if you're making less than 75 000
uh you're gonna get the 1400 stimulus
bill just to be absolutely clear
um but just keep this in mind so that
means let's say you're making
50 000 no no well they said it got
people out of poverty so i don't know
exactly what the poverty line is but
let's say you're making forty thousand
dollars
you've watched the economy collapse
around you restaurants are closed you
know all those blue collar jobs just
disappearing just
we've watched the middle class just get
crushed so you're making about forty
thousand dollars maybe you're working
maybe you're not working then the
government comes in and gives you
fourteen hundred dollars is anyone
getting out of poverty because of that
no so again it is a complete lie that is
the washington post and the washington
post
owned by jeff bezos who also owns amazon
is a prime purveyor of lies at this
point
if you want to see more on that i sent
out a little twitter thing on that this
morning just like the absolute drivel
that they're up to but i thought i would
do something here that they don't do
on cnn and that they don't do on msnbc i
thought we'd actually look
at some of the things that are in this
1.9
trillion dollar like why not a gajillion
you know
why not gajillion why not that but 1.9
trillion it's all made up drivel and
when you understand that then you can
see
how the swamp protects itself and if you
want some proof let's just go through
some of the bullet points here
uh so this is this is next to nothing
1.5 million earmarked for the seaway
international bridge which connects new
york to canada
have people been having a problem
getting from new york to canada i've
i've been up there and it's not a real
problem you just go from buffalo and
then you work your way
up into canada you know it's not it's
not that big of a problem but only 1.5
million i don't know what that has to do
with covid
uh 50 million for family planning going
to nonprofits
which will include parent planned
parenthood all right 50 million it's 1.9
trillion it's not that much
852 million for americorps uh americorps
vista and the national
senior service corps which is a
corporation for the national and
community service civic volunteer
agencies i'm not even sure what all of
that is and it doesn't really matter but
900 million dollars to that does that
have anything to do with coven
nobody knows and no one will ever find
out 470 million for the institute
of museum and library services at the
national endowment of arts and the
humanities if i'm not mistaken and we
found this out what about a year ago
nancy pelosi sits on the board of the
national endowment of arts or something
like that but really think about that so
almost 500 million dollars
to the institute of museum and library
services and the national endowment of
arts and humanities what does that have
to do with covid and the answer is
nothing
this is the swamp taking money from you
and using it
for its own pet projects this is why
politics suck this is why these people
suck
and are all horrible and if they give
you 1400 and you say thank you can i
have a little bit more you're part of
the problem
200 million for the institute museum and
library services
all right that sounded like what we just
did a minute ago uh 270 million funds
the national endowment of arts and the
humanities
so this is about a billion bucks we've
got just with the arts and the
humanities and everything else you know
i'm fairly certain that people are able
to paint now
and you can put things on instagram and
that's how you can get things out there
maybe the government doesn't have to
fund the arts anymore the way
maybe it once did and i think there's an
interesting philosophical argument about
what whether the government should fund
any of these things but
basically speaking i don't know if
people in the government have heard
about
instagram or pinterest or some of the
other
social media websites on the phone there
and that's how artists are able to
communicate with other human beings and
make money now it's really incredible
350 billion to bail out the 50 states
and the district of columbia so
the federal government makes up magical
number and it just gives it
to the states and by the way this is
what you can find videos of mine from a
year ago talking about this that
california was just going to crush the
economy knowing that the fed
would just come in and and pay the bill
even though again the money comes from
us
uh 128.5 billion to fund
k-12 education i mean i've been saying
this for a while but one of the last
things that i was able to kind of hang
my hat on and say oh i am an old school
liberal
is that i believe public education is
something the government should have
some involvement in
i'm not sure i can make that argument
anymore i mean now that we've seen
the department of education and
basically the the teachers unions which
are sort of a mafia organization at this
point just looks what
look what's happening here in california
where they're just refusing to go back
to work
we're going to put 128.5 billion to fund
k-12 education
what does that have to do with covid you
see what they're doing it's just to keep
the machine
well funded and screw you i think you
get the point
86 billion to save nearly 200 pension
plans insured by the pension benefit
guarantee corporation that maybe sounds
somewhat legit like if pension plans
really got hurt because of the market
because of kovid and that older people
who rely on those pensions for
retirement like there's something that
sounds somewhat legit there
39.6 billion to higher education that
sounds absolutely horrible
higher education is what has unleashed
all of this
woke evilness on us but what would the
system really want it would really want
to keep funding that because
that's how you keep control of people
and you make sure that they can't think
and 1.5 billion for amtrak the national
railroad passenger corporation we all
know about amtrak and they're
they're speedy trains that take you from
dc
to new york or anywhere else i don't
have a problem with amtrak but what does
this again have to do with covid if
are we to believe that if the federal
government didn't give amtrak 1.5
billion that amtrak was just going to
disappear
i pretty much doubt it and all this is
is that executives and politicians
and lobbyists they're all gonna make a
boatload of money and then the
washington post can we put
the tweet up one more time with that
headline the washington post
will then tell you that
the 1.9 trillion package enjoys wide
support across the country
oh i'm reading the subtitle here the
tweet itself biden stimulus showers
money on americans
sharply cutting poverty in a defining
move of presidency
does anything that i read there all of
those billions does any of that solve
poverty does any of that sharply cut
poverty again is there one person in the
united states
who's getting the check they're getting
the 1400 check and going honey
we're out we're not in poverty anymore
you want to have dinner at french
laundry
like it's just not happening we are
governed by morons and our politicians
are idiots
let me talk to you guys about gabby
insurance guys you know we're all
looking for ways to save money right
well everyone accept the government i
suppose
especially right now so let me ask you
this how do you like to keep an extra
961 dollars a year
in your pocket well that's how much
gabby customers save
per year on average on car and home
insurance gabby takes the pain out of
shopping for insurance by giving you
an apples to apples comparison of your
current coverage with 40 of the top
insurance providers
like progressive nationwide and
travelers just link your current
insurance account and in minutes you'll
be able to see quotes
for the exact same coverage you
currently have it's fast and easy and
gabby can show you if you've been
overpaying
i discovered great deals as well as new
insurance companies and was quickly able
to compare
the top five rates by seeing them listed
in order which made navigating
through the plan super easy like i
mentioned earlier gabby customers save
961 dollars per year on average
i bet that'd be nice to have in your
pocket and hopefully the government
won't take it from you
if they can't find you savings they'll
let you know so that you can relax
knowing that you have the best rate out
there and they'll never
sell your info so no annoying spam or
robo calls
you're probably overpaying on car and
home insurance see how much gabby can
save you it's totally free to check out
and there's no obligation go to
gabby.com
reuben that's gabi.com reuben gabi.com
reuben and now back to me all right guys
we added this story in just like five
minutes before
we started the show today because i saw
a tweet from this guy bernie sanders if
you haven't heard of this bernie sanders
he's an old curmudgeonly socialist who's
never really accomplished
anything he complains about a lot of
stuff he's been a senator
for about three decades he does have
three houses and he's a millionaire has
never really gotten his name on major
legislation or ever accomplished
anything he complains a lot
and then at the last minute once he
started to get a little momentum with
the people he always sells out
to the to the power so he did that when
hillary threw him under the bus he's
done it again here
with biden and by the way the movement
uh will be done with him soon enough
because
he is a 70-plus year-old millionaire and
he's white
and you know just old and complaining
and he's part of the problem
anyway uh bernie tweeted this out just
moments ago before we start here and
this really you know it takes a lot
you guys know come back to me for a sec
it takes a lot for me
to get annoyed right like i try to
deliver you guys the news with a little
light-heartedness a little
a little humor a little
tongue-in-cheekness um but
and politics is like it's not the sum
totality of my life so like i can talk
to you about it and give you a couple
stories and then
and then set you off on the on your way
for the rest of the day to
you know live your life that's all it
should be while everyone else is trying
to make you miserable about politics and
and you know
basically keep you locked in an
endlessly political state where they can
kind of manipulate you and control you i
don't really care for that
but this tweet actually annoyed me like
i came in here and i talked to my guys
and i was like this
seriously like everything that's wrong
with everything is summed up in this
tweet
by this buffoon old socialist so here's
the tweet this is bernie sanders just
about an hour ago
right wing republican well should i read
it like bernie i'll try to read it like
bernie
right wing republicans in california are
trying to recall gavin newsom for the
crime of telling people to wear masks
and for listening to scientists during
covet extremist republicans have done
enough to undermine democracy already
we must unite to oppose the repo in
california
that was pretty good i think for bernie
sanders impression it was pretty good
i'm bernie sanders huh
my bernie sanders it's a little bit of
jackie mason and i'm also like kind of
choking on a hot dog
um anyway i don't like you bernie
sanders and that's obvious but let's
just
unpack this uh tweet for just a second
right
wing republicans in california are
trying to recall gavin newsom
for the crime of telling people to wear
massive for listening to the science
during covet no
you're 100 wrong you old socialist
buffoon i have been to many rallies
where people are trying to open up the
state for the last year you can drive by
the main drag
off my house over here and restaurants
are closed indoor dining is still closed
in california even right now
gyms are still closed in california even
right now it's 80 and sunny in
california every day
okay gavin newsom has destroyed the
state when i have been
to these rallies these are not
republicans
you know what they are they're regular
decent people who are actually usually
apolitical or democrats who've been
mugged
by reality right who have had their
lives destroyed their livelihoods
destroyed their business is destroyed
and it's people like you that are
cheering it on the entire time so yes
we're recalling gavin newsom
two million people have signed it
already we only needed 1.5 and hopefully
once the recall happens he'll actually
be kicked out because he can run again
we have to get some better candidates
and hopefully that'll happen but
but you see what bernie does there it's
right-wing republicans in california
and it's like no it's not right-wing
republicans well first off even if it
was
right-wing republicans they have their
right to have their opinions
voiced and their voices heard that's one
thing but the other thing
is that these are regular people when
i've been to one of the
many of these rallies you know who i met
remember that woman the video went viral
we covered it here from pineapple hill
the restaurant that they closed her
restaurant wouldn't let her do anything
outdoors but then right next to it they
let a hollywood production
serve lunch to their people and i met
her with tears in her eyes about how
they've destroyed her life
we did a we did a meet and greet for my
locals community at a restaurant where
about 100 people showed up
last week and guess what nobody got sick
nobody dropped dead
and the the owner of the restaurant uh i
don't even know if he wants me to
mention the name of the restaurant
actually but the owner of this one who
was thrilled that we were there
um he had told me how he owned so many
other
restaurants and that he had
he had laid off something like a
thousand people by the way the owner of
a pineapple hill saloon which is the
woman from the video that went
viral her name's angela mardson there
might still be marsden there might still
be a gofundme for her which i
donated to and and these but the point
is that woman angela she was not a
republican you douchebag she was just a
regular person who wanted to go to work
ugh these people are disgusting and then
of course we're not listening to
scientists of course yes we are all the
backwards people you
enlighten people if we just gave you
enough money in power bernie
um yes then then we would be good like
you
um and they've the extremist republicans
have done enough to undermine democracy
already i know
extremist republicans who have fought to
let people go to work who have fought to
get
the government out of our lives we are
the extremists we're the extremists
and we must all unite to oppose the
recall in california well sorry sucker
you're a senator from another state on
another coast and we're going ahead with
that thing
and and mind your own business too and i
just can't wait
you know i've said it for years you can
find tweets of mine from three four
years ago
they will take out bernie one day okay i
said it before they will take out bernie
he is an old
rich white man and the the the movement
bernie the revolution the political
revolution
it's almost done with you you old hack
and
uh they don't they don't take kindly to
old rich men so
you're going down brother anyway i'm
looking forward to california being open
and we're going to do more
uh live meetups and we're going to do
one actually uh
in oc pretty soon in orange county
pretty soon i think i'm going to do one
with chef andrew gruel who if you're not
following this guy on twitter
this guy is like one of the primo chefs
probably in all of california if not all
of the country
and is making some seriously delicious
food and i know we had a ton of people
come to la from oc for our meet and
greet so i want to do one down
in in oc um okay
let's move on i think you got my you got
the point about bernie i don't like him
uh i think this story was super super
interesting and it's going to be way
underreported which is why i wanted to
talk about it
so there was over a couple days on
twitter and on some of the sites that
are the underbelly of the internet which
i need not mention
uh there was this meme of blue anon that
was starting to trend
and catch fire and the idea of it well
let's throw to the image of what of what
blue anon was and this is according
to urban dictionary i want to read it
perfectly
for you urban dictionary defined blue
anon as a loosely organized network of
democrat voters
politicians and media personalities who
spread left-wing conspiracy theories
such as the russia hoax jesse smellet
hoax ukraine hoax covington kid hoax and
brett kavanaugh hoax
blue and on adherents fervently believe
that the right wing
that right-wing extremists are going to
storm capitol hill
any day now and remove lawmakers for
office hence the need for deployment of
thousands of national guards stationed
at the u.s capitol okay so that was so
basically what happened here was the
meme makers of the internet cr somebody
somebody really brilliant came up with
blue and on obviously it's a reference
to q anon but it shows that because they
you know if you watch cnn and you and
you read the new york times and you're
just bashing your head
with a mallet all day long you would
think that q anon is the main driver of
everything that's happening in the world
right now but in fact
many of these conspiracy theories jesse
smallett brett kavanaugh the russia
thing all that these things have been
much more drivers of misinformation and
nonsense
than anything that cuanon ever did and
i'll i'll say something about q1 in just
a sec
um but anyway so it started trending and
people were posting memes and it was
catching fire online urban dictionary
posts
this image saying this is you know the
official definition of blue anon
and then you're not going to believe it
guys moments later
it was taken down off urban dictionary
and then you're not going to believe
what else happened then google
took down all of the references to blue
and on
huh now why would google the world's
largest search engine that's
organizing information for people to
know things i assume they want people to
know the truth
right uh why would they take down a
seemingly
uh jokey silly uh little definition of a
new phrase that just came up
well i can't figure out what could be
going on here uh
i think you see where i'm going with
this because this was against the
woksters because it was against the
democrats on the left
blue and on must be censored but we must
constantly make everybody think that q
anon
is a real thing i would argue at this
point there are far more people watching
msnbc and cnn
cnn that believe in q anon than actual q
and on followers but i will tell you
this one thing about q and i think
maybe maybe i mentioned this once on the
show so i went to many trump rallies
over the
months leading up to the election and
everyone i met there was great and i met
all kinds of people every walk of life
and it was fun and it was joyous and
there were american flags and
it was just absolutely absolutely
wonderful
i meant i only saw one reference to
queuing on there there one woman came up
to me she was a young pretty girl
probably in her early twenties
and she started asking me what i think
about q anon and she said dave you've
never talked about q anon on the show i
said i haven't talked about it on the
show i don't really know about it but
you know i try not to focus on
these little internet you know corner of
the internet things and i'm trying to do
some other stuff
and she got very angry and she literally
uh grabbed a bullhorn jumped up on the
stage and started screaming that dave
reuben's here dave rubin of the reuben
reports here and he doesn't believe in
queueing
a lot and by the way everybody looking
at her was basically walking away
obviously me and my guys started walking
away but everybody was looking her like
she was completely nuts and everything
else now
um if she's watching this right now
hopefully you've gotten a little bit out
of some of this stuff but the point is
that out of all the trump things that
i've done out of all the messages that i
got from trump supporters and
all this i never heard i never addressed
q once on the show i never felt it was
important enough to address once on the
show
and the one person that i ever
encountered that had anything to do with
q
was was sort of mocked and ignored by
people at a trump rally
so yet cnn will run a story every day on
how q
is the main driver of the of the
republican
movement or there was something i think
it was in the washington times a day or
two ago
where they did a whole thing on cue and
they just they literally were like a guy
named rick
said to us online that doo doo doo about
q
and the point is that this blue anon
thing that they are that google is now
censoring
is far more of a legit mainstream
conspiracy
sort of funnel the idea that the average
blue pill dullard that's watching
mainstream media
they bought the jesse smellet hoax right
they just tried to destroy
brett kavanaugh they bought the russia
hoax and the ukraine hoax
and then they refused to acknowledge
things like hunter biden's laptop and
everything else so which one seems more
mainstream and dangerous to you
is it q anon or is it blue and on
all right guys one more story for you
we're going to take it back to
california you know bernie sanders is
very concerned about what's happening in
california and in some ways there's
reason to be concerned about california
our governor's an idiot
we're still not open in a lot of ways i
might be having an illegal party at my
house on thursday night i've said too
much
but there is a new proposed bill in
california
which will require children's sections
in department stores to be gender
neutral yes that's right i'm not making
it up
it's completely attic idiotic this is
from the hill a proposed california bill
would require the majority of items
offered for children
in state department stores to be
organized in a gender-neutral
section cloy's toy clothes toys
and child care articles would be subject
to the law
which was introduced by assemblyman
assembly member
evan lowe democrat from campbell it
should should it pass
he goes on a little further to say here
this is a quote from
assembly member evan lowe rather than
having a separate boys or girls section
let's just have a kids section
let's make sure that we remove the kind
of stigma the type of bullying that we
see
especially in this day and age all right
you know i i said before that that
bernie sanders i didn't say nice things
about bernie sanders
evan lowe you're you're an idiot and
you're a ridiculous person who should
not
be in government i am fired up today
people it's the coffee it's
i had the strong coffee today excuse me
for just a moment
these people are ridiculous and let me
explain to you why they're ridiculous
they take your money then they give you
back peanuts and crumbs
and then they want you to thank them
thank you thank you okay i must see you
okay
this idiot thinks let's let's you know
what
i'm going to give him the benefit of the
doubt here i'm going to really try to do
this
let's say that there's some issue with
boys and girls and toys
that we're forcing somehow boys to play
with transformers and girls to play with
barbie but in fact most boys want to
play with barbies
most girls plan to play with
transformers or some version of
something like that
let's pretend that's kind of right okay
i'll even grant you that maybe there's
something to be said for that
that maybe we condition girls too much
to like pink
and boys too much to like blue and thus
we have a horrific stain on our society
i'll pretend
i'll go with you i'm with you on that
adventure even
if that is true which it's not but even
if it's true
what does it have to do with the
government to tell
a store how they should organize their
toy section
you people are authoritarian lunatics
masked under the guise of being
diverse and tolerant loving creatures
but you're anything other other than
that you think if we could
only give the government the power to
have
to tell toys r us or i guess they don't
exist anymore or kb toy store i guess
they don't exist anymore do any toy
stores exist anywhere get me a toy chain
for god sakes
target that still exists right yeah
because you were allowed to go to target
during kobe you couldn't go to the mom
and
pop store selling the same exact thing
but they that what this law would do
i've been to target okay i was at target
this weekend i like the candles
from chip and joanna gaines we like
those candles they've got that wood
candle it's a great candle okay
some guys like it some girls like it all
right but anyway there's a toy section
there and every now and again i do go
into the toy section
because i like seeing what what's the
latest with the transformers okay
i like seeing it all right sometimes
they have throwback transformers that
remind me when i was a kid i don't buy
them
but i see them right or i'll see the
star wars toys or whatever it is
now usually they are arranged it's it's
seemingly boys toys but no one stops the
girls from doing that they don't have
guards there
there's a lot i'm sorry young lady you
are not allowed here
with the gi joes or you know or they
don't have like some butch lesbian
guarding the women's
toys or something like that the point is
the idea that if you
think that you're creating a more
tolerant society by saying to the
government
that it should tell a private company
how it should organize its toy section
in the name of gender neutrality you're
an idiot
you're an idiot and we must start
calling you an idiot because you're an
idiot
so this guy should not be in campbell i
don't know where campbell california
is i'm guessing it's somewhere up north
have you ever heard of campbell
california i don't know where campbell
is i don't know who this guy is evan
lowe
but like if this is why you got in the
government like you're a government
official
and you think it's your job to tell a
toy store how they can arrange their
toys for boys and girls
you're a ridiculous person i've enjoyed
today's show i hope you enjoyed today's
show
it's been an interesting one and one
that i'll remember
you know uh this morning guys we put up
part one of my interview with dana
purino who has a new book out
all about uh empowerment that's a good
thing it's actually it's a really
interesting book
sort of like a i would say kind of like
a light sort of a little more
female focused version of jordan
peterson's 12 rules for life
but guess what men can read it too and
it doesn't have to be in a special
section it's wild
so you can get part one of that which
went up this morning on youtube the full
episode the full hour is already up
absolutely ad free at
reubenreport.locals.com
and as i've been teasing for the last
two or three weeks we have some major
major announcements coming with local
soon there is a ton
of good stuff happening i've been
working real hard if you think that i
seemingly am busy
with the stuff that i do here there's a
lot more happening on the local side
and i think maybe i'll make an
announcement about my uh my new book in
sometime this week maybe i'll make a
little announcement about that maybe
it'll have to
my publisher may not be happy about that
in the next little while i'm going to
make a little announcement on the
on the new book uh also we're working on
a florida
tour i i like seeing real human beings i
like
interacting with people drinking with
people
imbibing eating masticating with people
masticating i said masticating don't
demonetize us youtube i didn't say the
other i said masticating it's a totally
different thing
google it if you don't know what it is
it's legit it's legit
uh all right guys uh if you want to
communicate with me directly
reubenportlaugh.locals.com
have a great day everybody we will be
back tomorrow